bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
comment se former et en même temps
acquérir des compétences
professionnelles
la formation en alternance est désormais
la voie royale nous avons rencontré des
jeunes qui ont trouvé leur filière un
employeur nous dira pourquoi
l'apprentissage est pertinent pour les
entreprises et les apprenants cité des
métiers conseillère d'orientation centre
de formation nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des experts la formation en
alternance ou fait le point c'est parti
[Musique]
depuis mes deux ans de classe
préparatoire j'étais sûr de vouloir
faire de l'alternance
parce que pour moi c'est un tremplin qui
nous permet de nous expulser vers vers
le monde du travail
donc pour moi c'était primordial de
faire un master en alternance
ça permet de confronter le monde du
travail tel qu'il est on est considéré
comme un salarié
on est sur des missions qui sont longues
en matière de durée donc parfois sur
deux ans ou même plus et donc c'est
vachement plus intéressant longtemps
décrié le contrat d'apprentissage ou la
formation en alternance atteint depuis
deux ans des records depuis 2018 le
nombre d'apprentis a augmenté de 16%
ils étaient 450 8000 répartis dans toute
la france en juin 2019
en ile-de-france les yvelines se classe
parmi les trois premiers département
accueillant le plus d'apprentis dix
mille inscrits à la rentrée 2018 2019
j'ai fait le choix de l'université tout
d'abord pour la région parce que la
région pour moi était à découvrir et
aussi pour le classement de l'université
et pour son évolution parce que on voit
que au fur et à mesure des années il ya
une réelle évolution de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
et ça pour moi c'est très intéressant
iman occupe un poste à la direction des
systèmes d'information du groupe la
poste à guyancourt un contrat de deux
ans rythmée par deux semaines en
entreprise et une semaine à l'université
pour trouver son employeur iman à
profiter des opportunités du territoire
saint quentinois
j'ai été au forum ce qui emploie en
piste et là j'ai rencontré mon manager
actuellement il n'était pas en recherche
du tout d'alternants plus d'autres
profils profil haïti et donc j'ai quand
même laissé mon cv et ils sont aussi en
partenariat avec l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
visiblement séduit par le profil dimane
l'entreprise a contacté la jeune
postulantes pour un entretien et ça
aboutit montrer qu'on est intéressé par
l'entreprise montrer qu'on est motivé et
ça ça paye
[Musique]
motivé cassandra l'est tout autant
j'aime mes chevaux j'aime le monde du
cheval et c'est quelque chose qui m'a
vraiment extrêmement heureuse et
l'alternance c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux
ce qu'on parle de ce que j'aime donc ça
m'intéresse plus je suis un peu plus
motivés et après ça on peut je fais de
la pratique donc c'est ce qui est mieux
pour moi l'alternance peut-être
directement dans le vif du sujet
cassandra a commencé à monter à cheval à
trois ans et demi et a commencé le
travail d'écurie très tôt en
apprentissage à plaisir équitation
depuis août 2019
cassandra finira sa formation à la
bergerie nationale à rambouillet en juin
je sais faire tout ce qui est travail et
d'incurie les courses je sais pas encore
parfait est ce que justement ce que
j'apprends encore
mais oui je sais déjà mais pas encore à
prendre on ne sait jamais tout on now
continue toujours à prendre en ce
matière
[Musique]
je cherchais un enseignant à former
qu'est-ce qu'on va se présenter revoir
le profil m'a plu c'était en plus une
action avec la mission locale on vit sur
un métier passion donc c'est plus facile
effectivement avec des jeunes passionnés
comme ça alors dire voilà on va aller
vers ceux que vous aimez qu'on va
essayer de vous faire prendre du métier
prendre de l'expérience que vous aimez
plutôt que de les envoyer à l'école et
puis que sortie de l'école quand ils
arrivent dans des métiers le travail ça
correspond pas d'histoire pour leur a
appris ce jeune là une fois qu'ils
seront déploré une fois qu'ils seront
formés qui vont arriver sur le marché du
travail sont exactement de quoi il
s'agit d'autres jeunes sont en bac pro
conduite et gestion d'entreprise
hippiques tous les salariés de plaisir
équitation ont été formés en alternance
[Musique]
pour trouver son employeur et son école
cassandra s'est tourné vers la cité des
métiers la mission locale ici des
conseillers d'orientation guide aussi
les jeunes pour trouver leur voie
[Musique]
rien ne t'empêche d'ailleurs lé code de
commerce on a de l'apprentissage aussi
tu vas litres d'un j'allume mon à de
l'apprentissage ou six ans
amanda de la formation d'apprentissage
du simple diplôme d'ingénieur tu peux
pas faire un master on a des
partenariats des universités enfin tout
le conseil s voilà c'est la voie royale
pour les acquérir les compétences ce que
c'est ce qu'ont attention d'accord frais
cabine amirouche conseillère
d'information et d'orientation à la
chambre de commerce effectue
régulièrement des permanences à la cité
des métiers pour aider les jeunes dans
leur recherche filière écoles employeurs
nous le recevons pour valider son projet
professionnel
il ya beaucoup de jeunes en fait qui qui
manque de motivation recoupent des
motivations d'objectif puisque qu'on
trouve à l'école bon y'a pas
spécialement l'objectif ils ont jamais
mis les pieds sur le marché du travail
il n'y a pas de projet de deux objectifs
et de projection dans le milieu du
travail dans le milieu professionnel
pour ça que c'est intéressant qu'on
fasse on se teste frais cabine amirouche
utilise pour cela un logiciel mis en
place par un psychologue du travail en
fonction du profil du postulant les
filières possibles se dessine par ce
biais le jeune devient acteur de son
orientation
la conseillère elle lui donne les
ficelles pour exploiter ces résultats
jusqu'à la validation du choix définitif
vous hésitez à se renseigner auprès de
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines de venir rencontrer des
professionnels rencontrer des
professionnels
même à l'extérieur 1 pas spécialement au
niveau de la cité des métiers mais déjà
prendre des informations au niveau du
métier en lui-même du secteur
professionnel
quels sont les métiers dernière les
métiers qui recrutent si on n'a pas du
tout l'idée on peut commencer par ce
côté là et ensuite faire des stages
surtout les conventions sont délivrés
notamment par le département seulement
formation de la chambre de commerce de
la région paris ile-de-france qui permet
d'avoir des conventions pour faire les
stages de découverte
[Musique]
il existe deux dispositifs de
l'alternance le contrat de
professionnalisation les contrats
d'apprentissage
ce sont des contrats de travail soit à
durée déterminée soit durée indéterminée
pour des publics cibles notamment dans
le cadre du contrat de
professionnalisation
ce sont les jeunes de 16 à 25 ans
révolus et les demandeurs d'emploi de
plus de 26 ans dans le cadre du contrat
d'apprentissage
ce sont les jeunes de 16 à 29 ans
révolus ces contrats correspondent à un
besoin métiers du btp du tourisme de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration de
l'environnement de l'ingénierie ou
encore du numérique et de la
cybersécurité tous secteurs d'activité
peut proposer un contrat en alternance
ainsi que toute entreprise tpe pme
grands groupes ou encore associations
c'est quand même un investissement en
temps humain c'est pour ça qu'on met des
tuteurs ou des maîtres d'apprentissage
pour les accompagner à leur poste quand
ils sont en entreprise
ça demande un suivi c'est pas comme un
salarié qu'on embauche en contrat déjà
formés faut aussi prendre en
considération que ce jeune n'est pas
dans l'entreprise à temps plein la
finalité c'est l'obtention d'un diplôme
pour pouvoir mettre le jeune dans la vie
active financeurs partenaires
entreprises pôle emploi écoles
travaillent de concert pour aider les
jeunes c'est vraiment très ouvert et
très enrichissant aussi pour le jeune
puisque il perçoit une rémunération tout
en travaillant et tout en étant à
l'école c'est un bon pas pour pour
rentrer dans la vie active pouvoir
devenir autonome trouver un logement
ludovic lui a fait le choix d'un c ap
canalisations d'eau potable au centre de
formation des métiers du btp de trappes
choisi cette filière parce que déjà on
était en extérieur j'aime utiliser mes
mains faux dit il faut que je bouge je
suis très manuelle et je pensais
assemien pour être dans ce métier mais
pas seulement
ludovic avait besoin de se sentir utile
parce que on a besoin de l'eau pour pour
la vie de tous les jours pour manger
pour boire pour pour se laver une
formation de deux ans recruté par son
voisin ludovic a fait des stages pour
découvrir la profession originaire
d'eure-et-loir
il a suivi son chef de chantier qui lui
a conseillé le centre de formation de
trappes
on était aux portes ouvertes et puis ça
m'a plu donc après on a fait les
démarches
là on est en train de réaliser un réseau
d'eau potable donc un entraînement pour
pouvoir après sur les chantiers réalisés
se forme de deux réseaux ces matériaux
qu'on m'a enterré plus protégés par du
sable ans puis après la grave et après
ce sera sous lente
le cfm btp forme aux métiers du bâtiment
et des travaux publics du ceap et au bts
un secteur qui souffre d'un déficit
d'image et peinent à recruter
la meilleure façon pour moi de
d'attirer les jeunes c'est lors de ma
formation donc je transmet le savoir les
jeunes en sortent généralement contents
et naturellement vont communiquer par le
biais de leurs amis de leur entourage le
bouche à oreille marche ça très bien la
cité des métiers et la mission locale
là encore prête main forte au centre de
formation pour orienter les jeunes qui
seraient intéressés par ces filières
chaque mercredi de cfa ouvre ses portes
aux jeunes pour leur faire découvrir les
métiers
d'autres journées portes ouvertes ont
lieu quatre fois par an le samedi sont
des métiers nobles
j'irai parce qu'à utile à tous et pas
très valorisé peut-être depuis de
nombreuses années mais je pense que
aujourd'hui le confort qu'on a en
entreprise sur les chantiers
l'assistance des engins la sécurité est
un point très important c'est un métier
où on peut travailler dans le monde
entier c'est un métier où on va dire on
peut évoluer très rapidement si on suit
un parcours en alternance ou autre on
peut
évoluer sur mal en vie si on a en six
ans peut très bien avoir des
responsabilités sur des chantiers un
salaire qui est pas négligeable des
avantages aussi je vois plus de points
positifs que négatifs et en cas de
mauvais temps la clause intempéries
entre en jeu les ouvriers restent à la
maison et perçoivent une partie de leur
salaire
pourquoi
autre lieu autre formation pour les
jeunes apprenants
le lycée polyvalent dumont d'urville
amour pas ici l'offre de formation est à
la fois général technologique et
professionnel côté bac pro en alternance
le lycée propose deux formations l'une
en gestion administration en deux ans
l'autre en bts support à l'action en
edge et real le choix d'eva moi j'avais
commencé un bts muc en alternance avant
de faire cette formation là et donc
j'avais tout de suite bien aimé le fait
d'être moitié en entreprise moitié à
l'école et puis il ya la rémunération
ici c'est vrai qu'on a un peu plus
d'autres indépendance même si on est
encore jeunes d'avoir quand même un
petit peu la rémunération à côté et puis
puis c'est vrai que même pour après on
sait que ça va être un réel avantage
ça nous fait quand même une expérience
et puis on voit ce métier nous plaît du
coup un savant dosage qui séduit les
apprenants qui ne lâche pas si
facilement leur formation les jeunes qui
sont au bac pro en alternance eux vise
plutôt une entrée en bts et les bts pour
la plupart visent une licence
professionnelle à la suite de lob de
leur bts comme évidemment ça va leur
ouvrir beaucoup plus de portes
autre chance pour ces apprentis le
bassin d'emploi très important ici nous
avons quand même l'avantagé d'être dans
un bassin effectivement dans lequel il
ya énormément de d'entreprises et de
belles entreprises c'est quand même un
avantage pour nous pour nos alternant du
coup nous avons de très belles
entreprises comme partenaire en bts
le lycée obtient de très bons résultats
en 2019 le site a enregistré 100 % de
réussite en bac pro est en bts à l'heure
actuelle le lycée recherche des
structures sportives pour accueillir les
huit jeunes en alternance pour une année
sur la formation animation et gestion
projets dans le domaine sportif
je suis très intéressé par tout ce qui
est formation
donc je souhaite encore faire un master
sur une année par contre en alternance
soit poursuivre mes études soit trouvé
un emploi mais je préfère vais
poursuivre mes études pour avoir
vraiment un bon niveau en alternance
toujours je vais essayer de rester donc
là où je suis donc possibilité pour kim
pour qu'il garde en licence donc je vais
faire une licence management des
organisations en alternance
vous savez tous désormais sur la
formation en alternance à très bientôt
pour de nouvelles aventures
saint-quentinoise ciao
[Musique]